meanwhile bruh winfrey made sure that
she didn't get the premiere of Tyler
Perry's boo a madea Halloween and Oprah
stopped only to talk to et online Danny
direct oh yeah that's an interest right
there right and then run away let her
take old spotlight ha he loved the film
I love I laughed my aha the kale and I
worked together and I was literally
falling out of my seat okay wait for the
help me Jesus seem help me Jesus media
the strip for the night Madea movie also
included a special nod to Oprah Tyler's
friend of 15 years and earlier the
director writer producer and of course
accurate let us in on his color purple
oh my is over know about that line oh my
life I had to fight all my life ahead no
it's just probably gonna see tonight
she's watching the movie tonight so she
said I can't wait for her to see all my
life I had to fight the color purple
drank all my life I had it's good how's
it feel to have her support here tonight
oh it's awesome Oprah's just been
amazing all these years and have the
support is really great
you